new epstein information it's crazy how
little [ __ ] people care about epstein
anymore they real they were right yeah
you know what's crazy about the epstein
thing yep they whoever they is were
right they were sitting back and they
were going yeah they're going to care
about it they're going to make shirts
that say epstein didn't kill himself
they're going to have some like fodder
they're actually going to have more fun
with the fodder
than actually they care about getting a
result and they care about justice yeah
then they care about justice just
knowing what happened they just want
something to bicker about that's what we
are like that's what the mask thing is
right now that's what the vaccine thing
is like you just need uh things to
distract you right like you just need
something there's need to be something
we cry about we have to be polarized it
has to be teams and there always has to
be some discussion and it was everybody
hates trump and now there's not a figure
that everybody really hates like people
don't like
love biden or hate biden he's just kind
of like there and we don't have enough
access to him he doesn't say enough
things for us to like be pissed off him
so there needs to be another thing the
mask the vaccine whatever but with the
epson thing they were [ __ ] right
they're like they're gonna bicker about
it but life is too good for them to
actually do something and then they'll
just move on and we [ __ ] moved on and
now like new information came out which
is kind of interesting because it almost
like supports q anon a little bit the
new info and i think what this is what's
really cool about so the new what is
cuna q and believed that trump was
really out there to get the pedophiles
out of here right right that that's like
the the crux of their belief system
right it's like hey we're against
pedophilia and this guy
is in office because he wants to weed
out the pedophiles from
dc and hollywood he wants to get them
the [ __ ] out of here now
i never knew why the [ __ ] they believe
this [ __ ] right
but okay maybe they believe it this new
information comes out and basically
epstein thought
that
trump
had gotten him locked up so that he
would flip on bill clinton right
because trump believed that he had
information on clinton right right which
many people believe as clinton have
visited the island they've been to the
house a bunch etc
and
so essentially what happened is
ebscene goes okay trump's got me locked
up so that i can drop dime or whatever
is that the term on on clinton
and completely destroy the clinton's
chance to influence any sort of election
to be influential in politics just
destroy that [ __ ] name and that just
helps out uh trump
uh in general and the democratic party
takes a big hit because that is the you
know focal point they're essentially the
leaders of the party at that time right
um
there's also information i guess steve
bannon believed that epstein had some
[ __ ] on trump but what is interesting is
if the q a people are looking at this
like yo trump is about to expose clinton
they rightfully believe he's going after
pedophiles right what they don't know is
the reasoning behind it right he's not
doing it because he's like i got to get
the pedophiles out of here he's doing it
for self-preservation he's doing it
because he's like yo
i need to make sure that i can have as
much strength as possible so i need to
cut the legs out of the people that are
opposing me off the people that are
opposing 100 right so they have nothing
to stand on and so it is kind of funny
it's like you look at the queuing on
people you're like well you kind of
weren't right kind of weren't right kind
of you kind of weren't wrong yeah but
the other thing that
is damning is penta he might have had
info on trump and that's where q anon is
like well that's your guy this was
exposing everybody he might he got
exposed but i am curious
what were the things that they thought
he had on trump again there's still
talks about the p-tape and basically
this michael wolff guy he's the guy who
wrote the book fire and fury and fire
some [ __ ] like that back so he's going
to put out another book right and um
because trump makes money bro i know and
that's where a lot of it i'm like
are you exposing truths or do you just
need another hit yeah he wants another
hit and i think that he's going to you
know manipulate the facts yeah you know
it's just like what is it called
statistics right i think i took a
statistics class in college and they're
like there are three lies lies big lies
and statistics yeah and you can just
make a statistic work for whatever you
want this guy knows he's gonna sell way
more books going hey trump got pissed on
by russian hookers then no there was no
p
yeah you know like who's buying the book
if there's no p right right and i don't
even give a [ __ ] if he got peed on yeah
as long as they were above the age
you care i mean the guy wears makeup it
would be entertaining it would be a
funny story oh i'm talking about like in
terms of discrediting him as a
politician now but it does look weak for
the u.s president to get pissed off yeah
if he's paying for it peel me [ __ ] yeah
that's lit nah if you're getting pissed
on and you don't have a choice then
that's [ __ ] up but if you're telling
someone appealing you wouldn't get more
respect for him if you found he got
pissed off by russian hookers yeah the
only president to get pissed off
no way the only and if he pissed on
russian hookers that's i respect that
that's super insecure it's like you're
so insecure that you have to pay a girl
to pee on her so you could feel dominant
nah that's whack you're gonna get pissed
on
that you have to be degraded in order to
come down to
regular levels so a cuck is the most
manly guy on earth you're so secure it's
good if you're a wife you're just gonna
watch her get [ __ ] by somebody else
it's doing it to your wife
if that's what i can't do the cut the
the what's it called [ __ ] listen i'm not
secure enough i i i don't want a girl to
spit in my [ __ ] mouth dude i mean i
want to spit in the girl's mouth but i
can't i cause i'm not secure enough to
have a girl just [ __ ] dominate me
like that i don't like that [ __ ] at all
yeah i don't even like my girl to be
suggesting positions in sex
i'm driving
you know what i mean y'all be having
composters
be talking like that you know
you want to hop on top
get that spine straight
come on bro sometimes you got to go
pelvis to pelvis
that's the only way what if trump pulled
the r kelly like a comfy [ __ ] situation
that's fire
he peed on them or they peed on him no
on them but like was able to pull that
off at his age
that's
you got drugs and [ __ ] like that now
like he's so hopped up on like whatever
legal meth they got adderall
you know [ __ ] viagra bluetooth shout
outs to the chew like put that in with
that what
what i'm just saying like we out here
with performance enhancement yeah yeah
effective medication yeah old dudes
don't impress me no more
you know and they're like we out here
like did it used to impress you say what
did he used to impress you
yeah like if you were all exactly
pre-viagra and then they turned us on we
said it impressed us yeah even porn like
being able to nut on cue and that kind
of [ __ ] super impressive that is
impressive how does he say looking so
young though versus like trump over do
you think he looks young yeah that's
wild in terms of right no the evolution
of obama at the start of the presidency
versus like he started old obama started
younger
once you already look old
you don't age that much also i think
trump's preserved biden was bodying
people in the primaries and then aged 10
years or just as far as i think might
have been looking old yeah
and obama was pure black hair so he went
when he went gray that's when it's like
yo you've aged
okay trump just has a problem
[ __ ] already he's not yeah it's drugs
he's on meth
he's on the legal version of meth what
is it adderall or what's the other one
there's another one vivants vyvance is
another one there's another one
i don't know
it was what we use
i heard his name
[Music]
ritalin
these types of things yeah he's taking
b12 shots like the guy's getting all the
boosters so that he can have energy so
are all these politicians they're
[ __ ] 80 years old like if i don't
sleep eight hours i'm exhausted yeah you
tell me these people are sleeping four
hours at 80 years old they have energy
to perform and fly all around the
country you're saying they're not on
some [ __ ] they're on some [ __ ] 100 you
don't think elon musk is on [ __ ] he's
got your [ __ ] nootropics and all this
stuff allegedly they're on all this
guaranteed they have to be
allegedly allegedly but yes they
we don't need that tesla yes